Speaker 1: All right.
I did not plan to talk more about Sarah Palin.
I know many of you were hoping David never
mentioned Sarah Palin again.
Couple months ago, one month ago, I guess
six weeks ago, Sarah Palin said she would
only get vaccinated over her dead body.
She now has COVID.
And Sarah Palin's defamation suit against
the New York Times was scheduled to start
this week, and it's been delayed because she
has COVID.
We learned that she has COVID sometime after
Saturday Saturday, she was out at a restaurant
in Manhattan.
We then learned she has COVID, and yesterday
she was out again.
Sarah Palin is out at restaurants with COVID,
and there's a bunch of different elements
to this.
Freedom News reports that Sarah Palin is seen
dining at a Manhattan restaurant while waiting
for her trial to resume.
This was published last night.
She was seen dining and speaking with patrons
at Leo's Italian restaurant in the Upper East
Side of Manhattan following her positive COVID
test just two days prior.
She is seen with her group seated in the outdoor
area.
She's just going out to eat, I guess, with
COVID.
Let's take a look at a little bit of this
and I'll describe what's going on in the moment.
Unidentified: I got to be careful about it
because they spend a lot.
So if you're
Speaker 1: only listening today and not watching,
she's in one of these kind of like indoor
outdoor or outdoor indoor things, she's walking
around, she's, you know, knocking on the outdoor,
indoor kind of tent type thing that that is
going on there.
And she she has COVID.
So there's a couple of different interesting
things here.
One is there are vaccine requirements in Manhattan
for going to restaurants indoors.
And from what we know, on Saturday, she was
indoors.
So the first question is, is she lying about
being unvaccinated?
She's actually unvaccinated, she's actually
vaccinated, claiming she's unvaccinated, but
showed her vaccine thing?
Or did this restaurant not actually check
it, meaning they're violating the rules in
New York?
We don't really.
We don't really know.
The second part, though, and the bigger part
is we're talking about Saturday to Wednesday.
Right?
So she was out to eat Saturday.
She tested positive, presumably Sunday or
later.
She hasn't isolated for the required five
days.
She instead went out to dinner.
And this is completely irresponsible in every
way.
Just just there's no there's no math that
says this makes sense.
She was out Saturday, so presumably she wasn't
positive.
Then we learned she was positive Sunday.
So that gets to Sunday, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday.
You're talking about 72 hours later, and she's
already back out at a restaurant.
So this we knew that we've known for a long
time.
She's a disgusting person.
We've known for a long time that she's probably
a liar and whether she's lying about the vaccination.
We know, we don't know, but she's told all
sorts of other lies in the past, but she's
just out with COVID in New York City and awaiting
her defamation trial.
Now one other thing I do want to mention,
and this is just kind of this doesn't have
anything to do with Sarah Palin.
I genuinely don't know at this point.
You know, it's like it's outdoor indoor.
They've placed an indoor thing outdoors.
It's it's all enclosed in plastic with he
and I guess it's like slightly open.
I really don't care.
Like, I go to this stuff as well.
But to some degree, I find it funny when it's
like, what?
We've basically taken indoor dining and put
it outdoors.
Sometimes there's a completely and it's completely
enclosed.
I just don't know.
You know, I don't know what the risk level
is and how it varies in these different things.
I'm not doing actual indoor dining right now,
as I've said many times, but sometimes I look
at the outdoor ones and I'm like, I'm basically
indoors.
I'm just I'm outside of the restaurant, but
I'm clearly indoors in some kind of enclosed
thing.
Who knows?
Who knows, but that's what's going on.
Sarah Palin out with COVID out on
the town.